entre las opciones de tratamiento para
el cáncer se encuentra en las siguientes
cirugía radioterapia y quimioterapia
puede recibir uno o una combinación de
estos tratamientos dependiendo del
tamaño del tumor si se ha extendido y si
quisiera o no poder tener hijos cuenta
con varias opciones quirúrgicas según el
tipo y el estadio del cáncer
durante el estadio 1a temprano su
cirujano puede realizar una cotización
para retirar una porción en forma de
cono del cuello uterino un ejemplo de
cotización llamado el pp o cotización
por asad ya térmica utiliza un alambre
delgado calentado con electricidad para
retirar el tejido durante el estadio uno
ha avanzado y uno ve su cirujano puede
realizar una traqueotomía radical para
conservar su útero si desea poder tener
hijos más adelante
el cirujano retira el cuello uterino y
la parte superior de la vagina y coloca
un punto de sutura en el extremo
inferior del útero para que actúe como
una abertura interna artificial del
cuello uterino durante el estadio 1a
temprano su cirujano puede realizar una
histerectomía total retirando el útero y
el cuello uterino durante el estadio uno
ha avanzado y uno ve su cirujano puede
realizar una histerectomía radical
retirando el cuello uterino el tejido
que rodea el cuello uterino el útero y
parte de la vagina
durante una histerectomía total o una
radical su cirujano puede retirar otros
tejidos como las trompas de falopio los
ovarios o los ganglios linfáticos según
sea necesario si el cáncer vuelve a
presentarse su cirujano puede realizar
una excelente acción pélvica retirando
todos los órganos y tejidos al igual que
en una histerectomía radical además de
los ganglios linfáticos de la pelvis la
vejiga y la vagina el recto y el colon
dependiendo de donde se ha extendido el
cáncer la terapia de radiación o
radioterapia utiliza rayos de alta
energía para matar las células
cancerígenas sólo en el área tratada la
radioterapia del rayo externo o rbt se
dirige hacia la ubicación del cáncer
desde una máquina fuera del cuerpo la
braquiterapia o radioterapia interna se
dirige hacia la ubicación del cáncer
desde un dispositivo colocado dentro del
cuerpo la quimioterapia un tratamiento
sistémico utiliza fármacos para detener
el crecimiento de las células
cancerígenas eliminando las o evitando
su
celular una vez que los fármacos entran
en el torrente sanguíneo se desplazan y
llegan a las células cancerígenas de
todo el cuerpo